and to those who are tuning into us
about this ongoing incident at a
hospital in London this has come from
the Metropolitan Police they've just
released this information uh they say a
man has been arrested after two people
were assaulted at a North London
Hospital a man has been arrested
following a stabbing at Central
Middlesex Hospital the statement goes on
to say armed officers were among those
responding after calls at 1 18 so 18
minutes past one today
those cause reporting that two people
had been stab stabbed officers found two
people with stab injuries the first
victim has injuries that are being
treated as life-threatening the second
victim's injuries are not being treated
as life-threatening police arrested a
man outside the hospital he has also
been conveyed to hospital having
received injuries that are believed to
be self-inflicted his condition is being
treated as life-threatening officers
will remain in the hospital tool as
further searches are conducted but at
this time they are satisfied that no one
else is sought police are working to
establish the circumstances at this time
the incident is not being treated as
Terror related the hospital was
temporarily locked down but has now
reopened and will be operating Services
as normal there is a heightened police
presence at the hospital while we
investigate so that's a statement from
the Metropolitan Police a man has been
arrested after two people were stabbed
at Central Middlesex Hospital one of the
victims has injuries that are being
treated as life threatening the second
victim
their injuries are not being treated as
life-threatening the man arrested is in
hospital having received injuries that
are believed to be self-inflicted
officers are going to remain in the
hospital to conduct further searches but
are assuring people that at this time
they are satisfied that no one else is
being sought a